hey there hi welcome back to its Earth
weekly the Game of Thrones Q&A show
where we answer all of the biggest
questions you all had this week about
Game of Thrones we always start with the
big question we were left with after the
episode but first of course I'm Phil
Molina and my co-host lady Maude Garrett
and yes I this is the kind of pressing
I'm a good dad you're a bit sad yeah
this is all a facade immediately what
you're saying and so I just don't like
it when animals get hurt even if they're
mythical beasts get hurt
I'm sorry there was so much blood so
merely they did not need to be that
graphic I was watching with Eric and
Eric's like notice the Dragons anatomy
and O's like no on to look we just we
got to get through it yes okay so the
first question that is what we talk
about the big question and it actually
encompasses a lot of other questions
that people had about this episode
because you know I think that with all
these questions
we'll just sum it up with this one did
the night King set a trap that like
that's like mind-blowing realizing that
possibility by to buy so I guess a idea
is all this stuff that went down in this
last episode everything north of the
wall Danny getting involved at all that
all could have been exactly what the
night king wanted and was planning to
happen well first I already know that
the night king has some of the abilities
of a green sphere kind of like a psychic
how bran can log in to Raven to then see
things and also travel between time
there's every possibility that he also
has these particular set of skills
remember he can't see brands presents as
the three-eyed Rhett right well yeah so
he also grabbed brands arm and that
brain vision thing goes back in six and
so let's just say sure he's definitely a
greenseer just go with us on that but
what's greenseers officially they're
able to perceive the future it's called
a green dream that they had green dreams
uh-huh so let's just give that a given I
can't do so he can see the future and he
did lay all of this out on purpose if
you can see the future
so it would explain a few things if this
was a plan now remember when our boys
beyond the wall killed one
the White Walkers had little clan here
they saw that group and there's the one
dude with all the little guys friend I
just happened to be there and I started
killing them all and realize that when
they killed the big guy all the other
ones died I got that one yeah except one
hmm that wasn't like a plot hole did
they like well it seemed strange right
like oh how weird but if mr. night king
was setting a trap he would need bait
and so if he purposely sent out this
ranging party which was already kind of
weird by the way what were they doing
out there like on their own in such a
small little force I could easily be
defeated by our heroes by getting some
change um that's the thing we're going
to trust it yeah it's all making sense
possibly so if he purposely included
that one white who had not been turned
by the white Walker hence not dying when
they did kill the big guy
they'll so real it's obviously really
convenient for them and that's the
perfect little bait and a trap
for our heroes Jon Snow and crew yeah
and if you think about that the episode
kind of foreshadowed it if this is true
in that same moment actually because
that is exactly what Jon and his
company's own plan was they set up bait
I'm talking about that fire that would
attract the white Walker and his wife
and used it to lure them into a trap so
it's exact same move just a night king
playing that on them right that explains
that but then going forward a little bit
more evidence that he planned this whole
thing
maybe when Daenerys shows up with the
Dragons it was really convenient don't
you think that out of all the weapons
we've seen them have before they just
happen to all be holding these giant
sharp killing Spears yeah I I saw those
and I immediately like saw the point I
was like oh no it's going to happen and
I also made me think of candy canes at
Christmas at stabs or your mouth which
is how they make those I speakers go
ahead but we have we've seen normal
staffs with the White Walkers before
we've seen variations on ice weapons
there's ice swords actually in this shot
I think you can see I think that guy
down there has a nice sword oh yeah yeah
so we've seen variations on ice weapons
but
I spears are new and they're clearly
designed for this exact super mean giant
dragon puppy herding purpose now it
can't be a coincidence that they roll
out all of these right when they happen
to need them just as Daenerys is there
it's like well we've got five fuse ready
to guard but also these being a trap all
of this being a trap would address one
of the biggest questions that you all
had one of the top things that we were
asked this week was uh is there like a
home depot somewhere north of the wall
that you can just suddenly go pick up a
ton of huge chain that or like a
wildling bondage store or Sweden you
know that stuff happens with the
wildlings you get cold so probably also
with bears by the by which I kind of
happen I thought bearable obviously if
the night King died pun was unbearable
if the night King had planned all this
all along he'd have had plenty of time
to procure said change you'll have an
idea right of where the time to so when
you think about what kind of resources I
have in the North hardhome was a harbour
town so where they had a lot of ships
and these and the sickness and the
weight and the links of these change I
feel would be like obviously well how
they would anchor and more all the boats
and pull the boats into the harbor so
that's why they could exist well that's
where they would come from but they
wouldn't just carry them around like
normally unless you had a need for them
well and you like had a lot of time
planned for it yeah uh that was because
you knew you got a dragon you got a dig
out of a water hole right so basically
that would be the whole point of this
trap because now having Vissarion oh god
it's her favorite oh we need a new name
for him by the way because I wore one
I'm not going to call him an ice dragon
because that is a very different thing
there are ice dragons north of the wall
it's not a dead dragon oh she was
talking about when you have to follow
the the stars to the north look out for
the ice dragon with a blue eye actually
they do have lives they have but they
have like transparent wings they are
like reversed dragons kind of but this
is not one of those it's just an undead
dragon we got to come up with a knife
remember but for now I'm just going to
keep saying bazarian because
no I needed to feel like he's still kind
of alive and just like switch teams
because that would be fine for me but
yeah okay vissarion on his team it
wouldn't just be like a bonus no the
night king with a dragon is a game
changer this sways everything not just
because they now both have dragons
Daenerys still has two he's got one but
because of the ball we still haven't
seen how the undead plan to get past the
wall kind of dragon melt part of it and
can and give the night king a ride on
his back and just drop them up over the
other side
I like when when you lock yourself out
of the house and you have to hop the
fence and then like Jimmy the sliding
glass door and then you go open the
front door for all of your undead
friends and if this is definitely
breaking mentoring but yeah is he gonna
do that I mean he's gonna drag in now I
mean you know what a bag could do so
what a bear could do matter the dragon
yeah okay interesting that he had to
touch the dragon to resurrect it as well
and it wasn't just one of these Joey
gonna do already it's time to check in
with that map though we obviously see
where everyone has moved within the game
of Thrones and Westeros in itself they
fill it pull up that gorgeous man of
yours and let's check out to see what's
been going on easiest week we've ever
had probably Sam you're still probably
going your way we still don't know
exactly what's has been to gray when we
know we're going to see him next week
but otherwise we don't know so so over
there by Castle Rock that's also a lot
of time we cut you're on we think the
Lannisters are still in place there is
some Targaryen ports or so dragons down
but really come on all the action right
past Winterfell where those people are
all the same is right over here and
everyone is congregating near East walk
yeah now what I told you last week I
would have to like merge them onto one
thing just so we could fit them all so I
decide to give them all that brand of
brothers kind of sigil the Brotherhood
sizzle so they're all in there look at
our boys yes my baby yeah direction
they're all they're all eventually going
to go back south from where we left them
but they're all right there right off
the coast we have Daenerys we have to
put an X through one of the guys faces
in the Brotherhood day yeah I called
that too and I feel
but it also it just makes us take so
much like like higher this is your last
yeah yeah unless Melisandre gets back
but she's going yeah this is where
Danny's boats filled with all the sexual
tension in the world and that's what's
keeping it afloat is is just right off
of eastwatch-by-the-sea and then I
actually I know you see a stark circle
down there that's actually just because
Davos is still kind of on his own
hanging out around there but he might
who knows how he'll rearrange next week
we do know that a lot of people him
included are heading to King's Landing
that week but we'll get to that when we
get to our promo and our predictions
over there so I'm gonna happening so
fast yeah that was a map chicken it was
the easiest one I've ever had because
everybody went to the same place in the
episode stayed in mostly the same place
which is lovely yeah in itself alrighty
it's time for the Twitter Q&A and this
is when after the episode after you've
watched it you've got all these burning
questions you jump onto Twitter use the
hashtag Westeros weekly and ask away and
then of course will pick the questions
that seem to be getting the most
traction have instruments interesting
answers and instrument answers yes
horrible yeah with my trombone I said it
before you do the thing
people love it when we do aside this
barn you've ever heard all right but it
does let's get to those Twitter Q&A yeah
actually though there were some
questions that we're getting asked a ton
but have very quick answers so I decided
this time we're gonna do quickies which
is what John and Danny should be doing
right now and two cookies followed by
longi a Longclaw alright so we're just
going to fly through these real quick
get ready alright starting out a lot of
you asking what at vinícius given one
ask which is which dragon died which one
was it
what was the cesarean if you track him
in the sky he's the yellow ish one
that's his coloring and if you look
closely right here then you can see that
that's the coloring on his face and
that's him and if that's not enough
evidence well Emilia Clarke basically
said it in an interview so yeah sorry I
know those are like a screencap for the
caption yes the captions also said it's
a great wishes yeah
they didn't have to say screeches could
savor their exit
wails while dialing no no that's quickie
cookie baby at Husky 3 16 wants to know
like so many of you wanted to know what
the hell is going on with long haul
white as Jon emerges from the water is
it blinking is it being worked into
basically no it's like a trick of light
that's going on based on John's hand
placement I made a little like video
here that we can watch while I talk
about it and you'll just kind of see it
becomes apparent what you see him do it
a bunch of times I but basically if I
was trying to describe this you first
I'm gonna say something it's not true
but it makes it easier to understand
what if I said long-haul is hollow at
the eyes and you're seeing through the
hole that's kind of what's happening now
the only thing is long-haul actually is
not normally hollow at the eyes it has
gems in it at the eyes so it's actually
probably like Frost is showing up on the
stone and maybe some water splashing on
it or lighted reflect in a weird way
something like that but either way no
matter what it's because of Jon's hand
popping up that's it sorry you say that
I have a theory though yeah I go my wild
theories like ghost riding dragged on
and like the fact that they could be
Kraken soon what if ghosts soul is in
long cloth which is why we haven't seen
go so far why did he die we didn't die
but if we're not there there's like a
soulless wall walking around I mean who
knows where the hell go through but I'm
thinking a it's a carved white wolf in
the pummel and be he tried to give the
sword away Jorah wouldn't take it there
is something very very important about
having a white wolf it's the sauce come
on I like how profound you theory is but
that it shows itself in the idea of and
so that's why it blinks cuz I wanted
another soul I could go on by saying
that I actually think John died under
water and then it was like wings
resurrected and then had something to do
with the sword but hey a girl can dream
apparently though the director did
choose to include this particular shot
but you guys go through in the breakdown
so we won't say it right now you can
watch that video when it's out yeah he's
basically does it's not on purpose but
maybe there is some mean
mean it's in the break down next quickie
alright fine a bunch of you wanted to
know what's up with the relationship
between killing a white Walker and that
in turning killing the white so when you
destroy the like the Queen be the rest
of the swarm dies I mean I hold a yeah I
get the big shoes on him for a beehive
thing yeah yeah they have mental
connection yes I started going for yeah
not well but I tried it so interns I do
you think that the whites have a mental
connection with the white Walker the one
that turned them yes they do and you can
kind of see it when the hand kicked one
and they all groaned in response yeah
and I think that's a that's another one
that they go into in the breakdown you
talk about this the connections between
the white yeah Eric had a theory about
the hierarchy kind of of it or whatever
and goes into that very interesting
all right last quickie all right this
one's at me and ELISA wise aria acting
like such a brat
hmm very very very good question yeah I
can tell you she's 16 every girl is a
brat at sixteen I guarantee it it's just
frustrating as hell as all it is right I
still think this is all just some a
really convoluted way to just bring
about Littlefinger's demise that's where
I'm going with the purpose
yeah and they had to give them something
kind of manipulative related Eric and I
came up with some maybe deeper meaning
to the scene about what arias message
means like the flipping of the knife but
of course we get into that in the
breakdown the breakdown obviously since
we really take our time on the breakdown
scripts we get to dive in really deep
and get into stuff like what is the
meaning of the flip of the knife and
stuff now that has it so good I think
that could be a big thing okay a little
sink of death yeah a big thing
alrighty question two let's get into the
bigger questions that we can dive into a
little further let's start off with so
many --is question cuz I nailed that the
first time how long were John and team
surrounded by those whites so okay I
looked into this anime he
huge nerd so I wanted to figure it out
scientifically how we could define this
amount of time you would and yeah it
turns out it's really hard to estimate I
tried to get my fellow science nerds on
Twitter to figure out how quickly the
ice can refreeze in Arctic like
conditions and then to the point where
the thickness would be able to hold up
the weight of a white so like five or
six inches multiply that times all the
different whites crossing at different
you okay mod good yeah you lost me at
math yeah anywho the answers were also
all over the place because like who
knows it's a different weather system
but the only other thing we could use to
measure time is the distance covered by
our flying creatures so you guys
remember D equals R times T yeah okay
that's yep that's not yeah okay
well so we know that a raven gets that
are you cool you're going to go through
this distance equals rate times time
there you go yeah all right so I so we
know that a raven gets sent from east
watch to Dragonstone and using Westerosi
mileage estimates right if we went
outside math we would see there's a
pretty far apart
roughly we're going to estimate 1,500
miles so there's our D or distance and
then looking up the speed of a raven
that's going to be our rate that I found
to be 1,100 miles per day okay so it's
not quite the 1500 so now that means
that B one day and eight hours for the
raven to get to Dragonstone and then
look amazing so vertical we don't know
how fast dragons fly well real fast yeah
yeah it won't much I mean when you guys
when you calculate the wingspan
difference between the Ravens and the
Dragons but then you also take into
account their way you know wow that's
ridiculous how can you tell I mean have
to change in a magical time okay here's
the thing you know what's not fictional
hmm a pterosaur which was a dinosaur who
had a wingspan of like 35 feet and
drogon wingspan is like 32 ish P so we
actually have a real world
version of a dragon there's not around
anymore and that is what I use to figure
out how fast the dragon can go turns out
pterosaurs
these guys can go up to 80 miles per
hour they can fly like 12,000 miles
without stopping they're amazing anyway
if they need to go from Dragonstone back
up it would take them 18.75 hours to get
back to Eastwatch or just a little path
east watch where they are so that adds
up to just a little more than two days
and two hours so basically 48 hours on
that thing waiting but also yeah like
mazda this is all nonsense because magic
and so yeah it's like probably half that
time and who knows but math is fun they
looked awfully bored that's how I would
do that I'd be like how bored and tired
do they look and how long could a person
stay awake I have theories about what
they were doing while we weren't saying
that yeah that sounds wrong yeah bring
this up again later when we talk about
artwork
yeah torment we make do with what we
have he was like so extra weird as I
said but I love Gendry is all just like
oh my god don't touch my boy that's what
I came here anyway
directed did way on this particular
thing as well because a lot of people
brought it up and just said you know
what it's vague what a great answer yeah
that's not a fun answer actually
director you got to play along I love
the next question lovely this one was
kind of answered a bunch of different
ways with slight tweak so we decided to
just merge all together so basically the
question is was John kind of proposing
to Danny and also if they did yet if
they did get together despite what Danny
says could they actually have kids could
we see little snow well even though
there was some chemistry there and some
heavy hand-holding like you know sparks
flying already under the blanket
fingertips when he did say the Ben mini
comment it really does just indicate
that it's wearing fealty to Daenerys now
that she has promised to help to destroy
the knight King something that she's
been begging for he's like done you've
had my back you've seen what I want
we're in this together great right but
his alcohol you might win comment you'll
kind of felt like there maybe possibly a
marriage
- Anna - that could be brewing fingers
crossed and this of course is supported
by their undeniable chemistry the
holding hands and those looks really
look was there a lip bite at one stage
because there should have been look at
that look
oh baby boy yeah and she was planning
she had moments okay with Dragon when he
was petting dragon and then when he
wouldn't stop fighting when we're all
screaming at the television get on the
dragon go away there's a spear just
there she like for heroic idiots yeah
that's it well he's putting himself
first and then see these scars she's
finally realized that he really did
physically take a night oh my life for
the night watch me go no videos also
worth mentioning though that this isn't
just some tips at art here it's not you
design for me I do something for you
you've gotta remember that John has
declared himself king of the north and
then Danny says it she's the rightful
queen of all of Seven Kingdoms
Seven Kingdoms would count them north
yes exactly
sorry by John bending the knee he's also
essentially declaring a peace treaty for
after this war you know with the whole
White Walkers done that's all dusted
great so essentially it's going to bring
the north back under the Seven Kingdoms
and under Danny's rule that is unless I
decide to get married and then of course
that begs the question if they do get
married good day and really not have
children as we said right so like it's
like Daniels rub it in her face like I'm
barren everyone know that about me it's
like my one interesting fact at a party
look it all is going to come down to
Mary Mazdas prophecy that's that that
all which the head brought that Khal
Drogo into that like real dumb version
of him and he was like angsty where he's
like stare off into space
anyway she kind of you know curse
Danny's womb as one does yeah but she
also hinted that she could maybe still
have kids again though she said it
through a really [ __ ] prophecy yeah
about when she's gonna meet Drogo again
she said when the Sun rises in the West
and sets in the east when the Seas go
dry and mountains blow in the wind like
leaves when your womb quickens again and
you bear a living child so that's the
part that matters to us
here then he meaning Drogo will return
and not before wow that's like when pigs
fly right basically he's trying to be
all shitty like that it's a real shitty
way to say it is never gonna happen but
it's possible those things have already
happened the Sun rising in the east and
setting in the West well if you think of
the Sun of the Mad King born in Westeros
dying in the east and Essos yeah there's
also a Dorne based equivalent for the
book readers if you want that version
this sees going dry well Danny drained
the Dothraki sea when she killed all
those calls like straight up that area
that they're all in is called the
Dothraki sea and so she killed the calls
she also drained it by pulling all of
the horse riders out of there and
bringing them West yep and then the
thing about the mountains of blowing in
the wind like leaves right after she
killed all of them she gave this really
big speech to the Dothraki about them
siding with her on these hills of sand
there were like mountains of sand and if
you watched the scene it's super windy
it like all everyone's getting hit in
the face with fan but these like
mountains of sand they look like normal
Mouse's those are just sand piles its
head blown in and they're blowing the
wind of course there's also an alternate
theory I'll give you real quick that
maybe that could be the mountain getting
burned alive and it's his ashes blowing
in the wind and it's like poetic justice
because of what he did to Sandor
so that potentially could still happen
okay all right but who cares the very
next thing is then Danny's womb does
that quickening thing or you comes to
life so that can be sperm is not
quickening material quickens some things
into happening yes like ruining your
life but that could all be happening
right now or very soon long story short
I think yes she could get pregnant again
yes I agree it's not off the table she's
just saying it because a woman has
declared it but who knows and I've also
got some and I've also seen some
theories about how the Lord of Light
just may allow Danny to bear living
childs and she lost one of her
children dragon in a particular war so
it's like renewing in a way yeah but
still you brought it up again I don't
like that I'm sorry
technically not dead yeah there you go
let me see Phil Phil the linings blue
lining and finally we got another one
from at me analyzer who had another
great question about Brienne
specifically why does Littlefinger say
that bran would intercede between
somethin IO
what is his game why does then Sansa
sinned ran away well first off I think
that Littlefinger is obviously
indefinitely and slyly suggesting that
brand could actually step up and kill
aya on behalf of Sansa if push comes to
shove she's saying wait didn't brand
swear loyalty to both of you was one of
you we're going to try the other one she
would take care of that nudge nudge
nudge so it all so all it would take is
for Littlefinger to get ire out of the
picture and then him steps up can
continue to manipulate Sansa and then
kind of controls Winterfell which is
exactly what he wants that's his plan as
for Sansa sending Brianna way look I
just think that it's an extension of the
same thing in a way Sansa sees what
Littlefinger is trying to make happen
since Brienne away so that she won't
somehow end up killing aya right he's
she is so adamant in a moment like get
out of here you gotta go nobody wants
you here go go and she's like hitting
her with the newspaper on the nose and
don't rob her and then she finally goes
off but it's for her own good removing a
tool from little fingers at potential
influence oh and also perfect yes
segue speaking of influence it's time
for the Power Rankings now every single
week you will vote on who gets the power
this week notice is where we announce
the results obviously you're voting on
political and powerful influence who got
the most blood on their hands who was
the one puppeteering the motions of
gammatron I was excited so I voted angry
you did you voted in her will enough
after but I just couldn't help it and so
let me know who won all right coming at
number three at 11.7% it is Daenerys
Targaryen I mean she did come in she
saved the day
have you noticed that Jon Snow and his
army gets completely surrounded on every
single side and there isn't
way out until someone rescued him this
time it was Danny battle the bastard
last time not the veil came in two
dragons are better than the Knights of
the Vale if you aren't going to the tree
that he doesn't deal with with the neck
of the veil what's interesting is that
Danny though has lost I mean we got to
consider that Danny's three dragons are
like an army like they have the weight
of a huge huge army right she's like a
third of it I know this is devastating
and other people saying can they breed
can her dragons who are usually non-sex
they haven't heard of there are men or
women in the way the true lad can they
get together and somehow create another
right I think the idea is that dragons
being back means in general that Dragons
could return in a larger way so there's
hope there but in terms of whether or
not it's like you two are the daddy
dragons and you make you know whatever
your hermaphrodite dragon whatever it is
yeah they definitely don't go into that
so we just don't know but it's just also
she did slip a little bit she's been
higher up in the rankings before yeah
yeah I mean still on the board dark yeah
number two 14.8% we got Johnson er who's
me we saw him in action he took down a
lot of white his determination you can't
kill this guy even though he was left
behind he still came back alive yes I
won't die in the water yeah and it's
like I think he's not ever like I want
to say 25 minutes isn't it that you've
got about 30 seconds especially if
you're covered in clothes to get those
wet clothes off and start drying out
before you get hypothermia and Emilio's
nude so fast and they put them back in
the clothes don't everybody you most of
them was naked
no no that's the thing he has got like
and you could hear he's firs
cracking off him because I got first one
you do notice it's pretty subtle I
didn't catch him on my first viewing but
he is basically dead one the horses
trotting up yet on the wall he's just
like a corpse basically on top of it but
actually being somewhere so cold does
preserve brain function so you actually
die very slowly but also if you can be
resuscitated it'd be without mental
issues which that would have been real
weird and dark and he's just like his
brain is all messed up basically like
they keep being nice to him I'm starting
to feel like he's just a little bit
indestructible but teaming up with Danny
obviously a farmer that's yeah I've seen
a different side of each other and they
all
we bonding and connecting and they're
joining forces times being in the number
two position I'm guessing I also do like
really quick that you and I were talking
about this earlier that I John being
dunked into ice looks similar to Danny
burning bread I'm my theory again my
outlandish theories is that Danny can't
be burnt by fire I don't think John can
be killed with ice right which is like
awesome balance there I love everything
everything they do like remind us like
Danny is not the one right whether or
not she's Laura hi or John is like
they're both mighty yeah and people
really forget that who's number one the
one I voted for we ready for the night
king along with 60.6% of you guys that
is probably the biggest number one spot
we have ever had what their moment of 71
or something either way it is like not a
contract and that is pretty much 2/3
that is the alive Dragons voting oh god
I actually have a dogs out of you you
think I'd be a little more sensitive
about it but I mean this man still has
not uttered a word we have no idea what
he wants
all we know is that his aim with a spear
is unbelievable yeah he'd get drafted so
quick yeah so here's my reason for
voting for him on exam meters I just
straight-up was thinking about that idea
of like okay it could have just been a
lot of coincidences but it was so many
that I think yeah this was an I Kings
trap that he laid out and if he was
playing at that level
Littlefinger's like a joke great like
like the level a little finger plays out
the night king just became like a god
level villain and it's like okay well
then you win unless they come up with
some way to stop you from seeing the
future yeah I mean he does have an
Achilles heel and it was so obviously
and clearly pointed out you get rid of
him
every single one of these tens of
thousands of undead will die right but
it but if you can see the future then
it's harder to get rid of you copy a
Nicholas Cage movie about how he can go
any variety of ways you keep trying to
kill how many can dodge bullets because
you can talk future yeah hmm hey guy
that's actual Nic Cage yeah the night
king is Nicolas Cage
but he's also got you know like his
right hand men who they're not to be
trifled with I mean obviously there's a
huge enemies as well but he's got a he's
got a not ice dragon he couldn't under
dragon now so this guy he he
possibilities gained or a third of that
army size like plus the fact that he can
now get over the wall we wanted to and
maybe you can see the future and maybe
everyone's just a pawn in his game yeah
like yeah this guy's gonna win to power
and I kind of voted for him because
during this whole [ __ ] Don he looked
bored well that's the actor though to
like last week you're like he looked
like he was going to poop yes all from
food right I did change the actors the
old actor had a little bit more of like
a menacing look and this acted a little
like like when do they tell you to do
kegels like that's what he's doing
iced kegels uh but I either way I want
to stop talking about him because I feel
bad that I voted for the bad guy are
actual heroes this week and they didn't
make him the power ranking says for John
but they showed up and they represented
in the kill count that's it's our every
single weight we do track the kill count
who took out how many I mean obviously
through kind of hard to really guess and
be accurate with this because there's a
lot of undead so basically we've got the
fine men beyond the wall they did a lot
of direct killing a drug on did a lot of
fire blasting yeah we are going to count
the undead by the way because I just
want to see which of our guys is like
the most badass yes okay great it's a
little different this week we are going
to give you a few extra kill counts
gonna be a bunch yeah so on the top of
this week Danny oh no dragons we're
guessing it's about 162 162 slaughtered
with fire yeah that's not bad
great kills ah next this is pretty good
Jon Snow 31 he just wouldn't stop
hacking and slashing Jon Snow did a
fraction of like what the Danny and
three dragons did he did do that full-on
beast mode moment where like he
should've just gotten on drug on but
where he just like
rage of any kills just two more he had
that in him he was he was he was doing
great he also has the benefit of the
fact that he's got that blaring steel
sword so yeah if you have nice and down
yeah the next so out of our seven that
went beyond the wall not including the
death fodder was Jorah Gorman lot got
nineteen kill then I had two daggers
yeah scenes on human dragonglass Tigers
ah Andy yeah so he's able to take out
the bear which is from his house it was
pretty cool today actually yeah there
was a lot of great dragonglass
improvisation with their weapons if you
watch it again watch for that look at
their weapons now they've tied
dragonglass into it it also explains why
I guess flash takes out a white yeah
instead of having to burn them remove
the head a little bark
yeah John is most badass yeah 31 Jorah
pretty badass in nineteen we got a Thai
17 barrack and tormund 17 a page which
is really fantastic
turns out the fire sword does great
things and Tolman's just love killing
he's good at it yes life your life died
Bush his get ahead - yeah I was
completely surrounded and trampled green
- no he helped Keith Green he'd help me
please and I was like I will no I'm not
even there next was Hound who saved
torment at 13 which is great that Hannah
came in handy we've been a little lower
though sure and then benjin with 11 Oh
benjin and that's not a easy weapon to
wield by the way it's not all and the
only other thing that it reminds me of
the whatever that thing is what is that
called
the glass bug zapper yeah I medieval
hundred I in the forest temple of Legend
of Zelda Ocarina of Time when you have
the ghosts they had that as well but
yeah anyway moving on next
McKnight King Army only took out seven
of our guys and they were almost all red
shirts yeah pretty much
and I were I killed quite brutally and
you're not fun way but you don't
remember you don't know the recognize
device you like yeah but did you also
notice that they look like each other
too so they oh I thought you already
dead so like I already mourned yeah feel
nothing and my boy Gandhari Gendry was
on the board with one hey you know
getting on the board when there's like
seven of you and
we got on the board on the board so all
right he's on the board you know he's
like man I'm so a Candace buy all right
bill beep Emma especially for it and
then have to otherwise make a run for
you hammer just running uh yeah that
happened to me in woodshop once where I
made a cool little boat and I showed it
to someone who said give me that boat
okay yeah bring that guy Momo by the way
for giving us these numbers we really
appreciate it we wanted to film today so
we couldn't stop and count all of that
yeah the moma hot air bag could've done
it without you well it's time in the
episode where we watched the preview for
next week and weigh in what we think
will happen got predictions predictions
on the other side but this is a season
finale
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there is only one war that matters and
it is here so many characters meeting
your soul either they're all in the same
scene together my prediction is that
they realize they've traveled all the
way north they nearly got killed by the
night king they lost a dragon just to
show so see a white and for her to
dismiss it instantly I was feeling dude
I don't going to be solved she has she
is in such denial about so much I don't
think that she's going to take the full
white of the situation no no one did not
work a little bit in my accent ugh but I
would I will give you as I'll back up
your claim that Cersei is basically just
not gonna do what she's supposed to do
do you think I mean that army all of
them when you see the unsullied and the
Dothraki all there together is so like
I'm nervous like I look like that your
dragons nearby too like did I think for
that reason
Cersei actually I think maybe on the
surface she'll kind of like give a smirk
or a nod or something I've got a plan
but I think yeah she absolutely is like
here's what I do what no one's expecting
and here's how I have all my enemies
like get blindsided
honestly like I'll just throw those
others as we're heading toward to Denali
I mean just Cersei like tried to set up
some sort of alliance with the my king
oh my god you know like something
terrible like that like ah I think she
poisoned Tyrion no really yeah I think
the fact that cheering had come into her
space she's got all of her people around
I think she's organized something weird
cheering drop whether it happened
straight away or later who knows but
something's up um one thing they did not
show in this teaser but just makes sense
it has to happen is the Hound bringing
the white right we saw him get put in
the boat so now the Hound is going to be
in King's Landing oh hey who else is in
King's Landing the mountain
I'm not saying cleganebowl confirmed but
please Clegane bowl confirm count is
going to say that the mountain Azazel
that he is dead and then is that going
to so when you think about it John has
died and come back the mountain has died
and come back the White has died and
come back how are they different from
each other
and I think that that's the kind of
evidence that says he's going to get
involved with to be like well John
you're an undead person
I don't know attenti may-maybe is by the
way I was bowling I want brothers to
fight it Sue's finale so I want starts
to do something crazy and I want a
little finger to die I think yes please
oh I made a really good point where I
get to next season little fingers and he
Mia and I did read this I can't claim it
but I love it I is going to kill
Littlefinger and then continue to wear
his face and show manipulate the night
for the face to still do get
Littlefinger and an actor he doesn't say
goodbye just yet but he still plays a
duck it of all actors actually awesome
yeah the fact that this character is
just okay inert now yeah yeah alright
guys you made by the way amazing artwork
for our team that went north beyond the
wall and you combine them with famous
movies yeah I can see all of that at the
end of this video they're so amazing I'm
very impressed by you guys but for next
week yeah what are we gonna get everyone
to do this is the last chance yeah I'm
very excited by this so I want you guys
to the thing that I was joking about
earlier dive in there and show us what
was going on while we did not see the
guys on the the island of ice don't get
gross with it okay know what it does
your brain that does it I actually
thought you're gonna say what happened
with Denny and John when they're in the
ship together
no I ship it come on that one works yeah
well done so show us how the Hound and
John all the people spent their time
just waiting there sitting to the play
games let us know what you think they
were up to over that 48 hours 50 hours
yeah how we calculated to do long yeah
but that'll be at the end of next week's
video stay tuned at the end of this week
for the N screen artwork also remember
to get in touch with us without our work
with the hashtag yes westward Westeros
weekly Wow well done mode
the episode you nearly made it oh and
you can also tweet at me on at mode
Garrett and I'm at fimo follow at new
rock stars for how to get the power pole
we put that out every week yes but
otherwise I talk to us those ways I'm so
amazed at the eighth season finale
already here but I also equate him not
wait for it do you think we'll have a
leak we've had so many already I hope
not
go watch the breakdown guys it's we're
gonna get some real good stuff there you
see you next week bye guys bye boys